Hello everyone.
Very great to see you all and thanks so
much for your precious time you're
sharing with us, with me. Hi Tim.
So, um yeah, I'm David, founder and CEO
of Neura Robotics and I'm here to talk a
little bit about my personal vision in
the same time also the mission Neura
Robotics is on and um
like the way we see the world also going
forward uh forward in physically AI in
the same time also what we think is a
differentiator and uh in how we do
things and what we do.
So,
to explain a little bit about Neura
itself, we are about 1,500 people in uh
based in the southern part of Germany,
so Metzingen to be precise, and um with
the aim of making robots cognitive. So,
it means give the robots
the abilities to hear, see, and feel and
in the same time also react fully
autonomously on different kind of topics
and tasks.
So,
the other claim I would like to do today
is actually that I do believe that
robotics or physically AI
will take every physical task in the
future. So, it will actually do any kind
of physical task. I know it sounds
actually pretty big and the same time
for some people maybe a little scary,
but I do believe this is the biggest
chance we as humanity have today to
actually use machines as machines while
using ro humans actually as humans uh in
the world and basically making the next
step of humanity.
So,
the reason for today actually having
this nice events in the same time also a
lot of people going crazy about robotics
and seeing that as a as a actually like
kind of a hype
um in robotics is basically very
naturally driven. So, one because we do
see actually going further like even in
a very close future that like we are
actually facing one of the biggest
challenges actually on humanity right
now. So if you're looking into Europe,
you will have about 7 million
less human labor by 2030 while actually
China has even a bigger issue about more
than 80 million less human labors while
going actually also to Japan, all US in
about let's say 6 to 10 million less
human labor by 2030. It means actually
there is more people getting actually
retired with skills than actually new
people getting trained with new skills.
And if you are looking actually a little
bit more precise then you will also see
that the most people actually retire
with skills are actually in the space of
physical task and work. While actually
the new people with skills getting
trained are not the most are not in
physical. So the most people don't even
want to make this task anymore and this
is actually why the physical
work will actually require like a new
solution, some technology which can
actually take over and basically bridge
the time the same time also one day take
over the whole task. But the other I
think even more important KPI we are
focused on is actually the time to
skill.
Because the reason for
physically I and robotics actually
taking over every physical task it has
something to do actually with the way of
how humans are getting trained for
physical task. If you're looking into
the lowest value bringing work, so it
means task which don't require any
quality dependencies or any let's say
special skill sets.
Here like we are talking about let's say
not less than 3 hours of instruction and
training time for a human to change a
department or start a new task in the
work or new work.
And if you're looking into actually
robotics and this is also the core part
we are focused on, you will see actually
that even today already, there is
possibilities like of training a robot
for
let's say for a new skill in last and
let's say a couple of hours instead of
actually weeks, months or years like
humans do. And the other big advantage
we have is that like the good thing
about robots and physical AI is that
a new vessel for knowledge. So it means
and the good thing is that you can
transfer it by one click while a human
needs to learn it again and again every
time it's a human retires or changing
work,
changing the job or actually getting
sick. You can't just click on something
and have the the new skill actually
transferred and this is actually the
case in robotics and this is also why we
are seeing that in the future, in the
very close future, there will be like
there will be no let's say how to say
it.
It will not make sense to actually use
humans for all the physical task and
train them for new task because there is
actually robots much faster in physical
AI especially.
And then I would like to also talk about
another topic we are focused on right
now a lot and because today we hear a
lot, okay, is actually hardware not
commodity already like and do we not
have to focus just on
the brain part mainly? Mainly I think
the most people would agree but here I
do need to say like it is not the case
yet but very soon. So and what I'm
talking about is actually building a
hardware which is capable to send
actually the right data to actually
compute infrastructure to create the
right knowledge. And here I love to make
that example of
basically swimming because this is the
biggest differentiator of like a vision
language models to what we call
perception language model, a model which
is multimodal and uh it it basically
receives more than just vision data. And
why is this important?
It's it's like and that's actually where
I love to use the swimming
example is because like with swimming
you can't learn the most of the physical
task actually just with your brain. And
you can't just basically uh watch a
video for a year, 2 years, 5 years,
whatever and be a swimmer afterwards.
And the reason for that is very simple
to explain. It's not just how to say it
because because you you can't learn
everything with your brain. There is
more actually what a human has. You're
going into the water and then you're
actually training something else than
your brain. It's actually your nervous
system and the reflexes of your body so
of your muscles. It's actually memory of
factor of your muscle. So and this is
also applying for the most of the task
in the physical world. Everything what's
moving, everything what's flexible,
everything where you have to react on,
you're using more than a brain. And this
is also something what we are right now
mainly working on is like not building
on existing standard but actually
setting a new standard for that. We call
smart limb concept. So
what we build is actually
like like first yes, you're having a
brain and then the second actually you
do have a nervous system. Here we're
working also with Qualcomm on a solution
for that. We we call it like limb
concept because it has seven limbs like
a nervous system which is super reactive
and the same time trainable for actually
abstract training we call. It's like
you're gaining some knowledge into your
body
while actually having not how to say it,
not making decisions but actually very
fast reactions
on the body side.
So if you have everything like that in
place, then actually a new thing the
issue appears and this is basically also
the data sets because I think this is
something we hear here all the time.
It's about
the data, which is not existing yet, or
so first of all, I think very important
to mention, it's not just about having
physical data somehow,
because this is what we hear and see
right now a lot. I get a lot of
messages, "Hey, we have a lot of data.
You want to buy it?" And here is I think
very important what kind of data and
where does it come from? So and for that
you first need to define, as I said,
like the
uh the sensorization, because that's
where the sensor the data come from, and
then basically having the right compute
infrastructure to enable actually this,
let's say, thinking of brain and
actually having a reaction of the
nervous system.
And how to train that? And this is
something where we are right now mainly
focusing on. It's also why we raised a
lot of money for is basically building
the infrastructure for physical AI. And
what I mean by that is actually real
physical places where we place, let's
say,
100 unit humanoids or different form
factors, if you want to, and in the same
time giving everyone the tools instead
of the solution. So it means having a
platform we call Neuroverse, where you
can find the tools, so you don't have to
have the knowledge about how AI is
created. You just have a start record
button
by manipulating actually a task, stop
record button, and then the third
actually train. And what you do with
that is actually you're fine-tuning the
foundation model we built actually to
give them a special knowledge. And this
is also one of the other core
differentiator of what we are building
is basically we call brain account. It's
actually that we don't want to, let's
say, commoditize basically the knowledge
as everyone tries to do as we did
actually with Anthropic and with OpenAI
right now. You're having basically a
brain which knows everything. It sounds
also pretty good, but in reality it
brings also a certain impact like like
to
especially this one which are basically
how to say it
where they
like where they took all the knowledge
away from, are you? And if you're
looking into the physically eye space, I
think it's it's kind of danger to just
say like we are here to bring one to
build one brain and train one brain
which can do everything because it
doesn't make sense because the reason
for all existence of all the companies
is mainly behind the knowledge they have
and how do they think I mean in process
knowledge and also know-how, knowledge
how they actually do things different to
others. So this is also differentiator
of what we are building to others is
basically we're enabling everyone to
actually have their own brain account,
basically a fine-tuned model of their
knowledge of how they do things to
actually also in the future having the
possibility to monetize it and actually
license it to the world because this is
how we see the world going further.
I don't think it will be like it is
today that you're having your physical
company and like Foxconn or whatever. I
do think these companies will have
basically a brain account which is
pretty capable and they will license it
to you so you have your possibilities to
do the same production capabilities as
they have in Taiwan, in China and
whatever but actually on your place
in your factory.
And this is also like say what we are
mainly right now working on is actually
first building the foundation model to
give like all the general knowledge to
the robot of how does the physically eye
let's say physical world around you
actually interact, like how how does
everything move? How is it dynamically
different? How do you move things that
they're actually how do you correct
them? How do you react on things? This
is a task which we are doing today.
This is very general and at the same
time what we are doing is basically also
getting a lot of data out of humans. So,
we are having about 1,000 employees in
data suits
where we are gaining a lot of data
surely which actually the human robot
disability gap, but actually combining
that with real world, let's say physical
data out of the robot with all the
disabilities, you're actually enabling
like a very smart device.
Again,
it is capable to do general things as
mostly humans are. All right? So, it it
means actually so why why is this so
important and why do we think this is
the way how we should do things is that
this is how the physical world works.
All right? The industrial world works.
Even you are the best expert in actually
manufacturing,
believe me, if you're coming now to My
Fab
and try to start to to build one of my
robots,
even you're the best expert, you will
not be able to do that. So, and the
reason for that is actually that there
is a little general know- knowledge in
every of the companies which we want to
actually bring on the platform and
actually into this brain accounts of
everyone.
And then the other claim I would like to
do today is actually it is not enough
to just have a smart robot.
Because this is actually what the world
works right now on is like making this
robot as smart as possible.
Uh this is the same happens also in the
autonomous driving industries. You're
trying to make the the the car as smart
as possible. And believe me, this is not
a solution. This is not this how it will
end up and this is also what we are
working on. Through the Neural Voice
platform, you're adding another layer
which is the layer above the robot. So,
it means the orchestration layer, a
layer which is actually orchestrating
everything around you.
A layer like to explain it to you
faster, it doesn't make sense to have a
robot walking up the stairs to open a
fridge to see there's nothing inside
while actually having a layer bath which
is connected to the fridge and actually
tells you already right information
orchestrates actually the whole world
around you. This is what we call
Neuroverse. This is also something we
just presented 2 weeks ago and and and
you ask again on the automate where we
shown actually you could simply have
like a chat you talk to and everything
around you actually get adjusted and
actually taking care of because there is
a brain behind everything and
orchestrates everything.
So, what I mean by the platform
Neuroverse, this is actually a platform
we build right now. It's also a
developer environment. So, it's not just
platform which can do everything, but
it's a platform which enables you for
being able to do everything. So, it's
basically the communication layer
between devices and the same time
actually devices to sensors, sensors to
AI models and in the same time also even
the whole infrastructure. So, we do
believe that the platform we are
building right now will also one day
connect every autonomous driving car
with in the traffic light with any
cameras on the street because they are
bringing the right information to
actually give you let's say a safe
driving and the safe environment and not
just a smart robot. The same time, this
is actually also the marketplace
we built to to actually enable basically
everyone to distribute their knowledge
into the world actually and connect the
world in that sense. I I I don't think
the video will make a lot of sense now
to show. So, I will just basically
come here to an end. So, to give you a a
little bit of what is Neura about. So,
the most see us as a robotics company.
So, yes, we do build robots. Why we
build robots? The simple reason is we do
need to define a hardware which sends
actually the right information to the
right compute. So, we define also the
right compute to actually enable
physically I am real, so it means
reactive on the real world. And then
what we are building is actually also,
let's say, a distribution network,
basically a platform above of all them,
which is connecting all these devices
and also let you distribute basically
all your knowledge and to others. So,
everyone has basically, how do you say
it?
A solution for the future while not
being an expert. So, this is where we
see
physically I going and what we basically
build in Metzingen out of Stuttgart. So,
thank you for your precious time.
Um and yeah, looking forward to meet you
all. So, thanks.